- I last saw you when you
presented at the Billboard Awards
and, so you knew something
happened to me and
I had no idea it was happening.
- Well, that's a live show, right?
- Yes.
- Okay, so.
- Very, do you know
how many quick changes?
Oh my God.
- Well, I do and this kinda,
the story kinda goes along with that.
- Yeah.
- So they've got her just
a little, sort of context.
She's hosting the show,
and they've got her,
you know, I mean running
back and forth, back and forth.
- Yes.
- There's no time to stop.
You are like a freight train, man.
It's like coming and going.
- I feel like Reba in the
nineties with all the changes.
- It's unreal.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But I'm standing there
and you're coming through,
and you've got this train on your dress.
- Yes.
- And you're flying by,
and there's this dude that just kinda,
he just...
Do we have the technology?
Can I stand?
(Kelly laughing and clapping)
He just stands like this
and he starts talking
to someone, and he stands on your dress.
And you're flying by.
- Ohhhhh.
- I mean (slaps hands
together) you're like a shot.
- Well, that would've been quite.
- It would've been a different show.
- Yeah.
It would've been brought
to you by Spanx and hoes.
- That's right, that's right.
- Yeah, ha ha.
- And I just looked at him.
I didn't know the guy,
but we just connected
somehow and made eye contact.
It was a dude thing, and I was like,
"raise your right foot."
And he literally just went like this,
he looked at me and he goes, "whoop."
And he raised his right and you "boop,"
and you were gone.
- Oh my gosh!
- Yeah.
- Literally, that would have
been like a very different
version of "Single Ladies."
(audience laughing)
That whole, that whole look would've been.
Thank you from the bottom of my heart.
- You're very welcome, anytime.
- 'Cause we are racing in and out of there
and stuff like that happens all the time.
so thank you.
- Yeah, you're welcome.